[Musik]
martin luther king ein eindrückliches
filmdokument über die hintergründe
seiner ermordung und über seinen einsatz
für gewaltlosen widerstand gegen
rassentrennung und rassismus rassismus
ist auch in der schweiz verbreitet die
formen sind meist subtil nicht
offensichtlich das besagen verschiedene
studien was ist rassismus und was können
wir gegen rassismus unternehmen darüber
diskutiere ich mit dennis f es ist
soziologin und forscht an der
universität neuenburg sie hat vor kurzem
auch eine studie zum thema rassismus in
der schweiz veröffentlicht fatima moniz
ist sozial anthropologin und engagiert
sich gegen rassismus harmonie ist martin
luther king für sie ein vorbild wenn wir
gerade diesen film gesehen haben
ja natürlich auf eine art vor allem auch
weil er ein sehr guter redner war
ich glaube dass wenn man über martin
luther king spricht oft einfach diese
komponente der gewaltlosigkeit und des
noblen revolutionärs ein bisschen zu
krass betont weil es glaube ich wichtig
ist zu sehen dass die die die strategie
die martin luther king hatte war auf
unrecht aufmerksam zu machen indem man
es demonstriert also man geht auf die
straße
man wird angegriffen von der polizei und
zeigt somit dass das dass das böse
gesicht der der der rassistischen gewalt
und die frage heute wäre für mich ob das
überhaupt noch funktioniert kann man uns
überhaupt noch schocken mit
rassistischer gewalt wie ist es denn in
der schweiz heute ist es gefährlich sich
gegen rassismus einzusetzen
direkt gefährlich nicht also tätigkeiten
gibt es in der schweiz zum glück selten
aber es ist ein schwieriges thema es ist
ein gesamtes thema wie ich auch gemerkt
habe als ich diese studie zum rassismus
gegen schwarze personen insbesondere
gemacht habe war ich recht erstaunt dass
das thema durch noch so umtreibt und
relativ unglaublich amt ist
weil das jahre her ist mit martin luther
king in amerika eine andere situation
aber was haben sie denn da
herausgefunden oder was hat sie so
erstaunt das ist schwierig ist über
rassismus zu sprechen weil die
betroffenen selbst die schwarzen frauen
und männer vermeiden dass weil sie auch
oft merken dass es unbequem ist weil
viele weiße eigentlich sich mit
rassismus gar nicht unbedingt
konfrontieren möchten und auch nicht
müssen wenn sie denn nicht konkret
bezüge haben zb in der familie oder an
der arbeit
ich möchte mal bei ihnen noch anknüpfen
sie haben ja gesagt auch die rhetorik
von martin luther king hat sie
beeindruckt sie sind ja auch spoken word
poetry
sie haben vor wenigen tagen bei den
schweizer meisterschaften im poetry slam
in winterthur gemeinsam mit laurin buser
den zweiten platz gewonnen
rassismus ist auch manchmal bei ihren
auftritten ein thema wie im folgenden
filmausschnitt am rassismus kritischen
festival in der roten fabrik in zürich
im jahr 2015
wir sehen hier wie sie auch mit witz und
humor gegen rassismus ankämpfen
rassismus ich muss er immer über
rassismus reden also die beste
geschichte war eigentlich dieser typ der
so hinter die bühne kommt zu mir und und
wissen will wo ich herkomme und ich will
gerade ausholen thomas beyer noch so aus
münchen ja weil freilich und so da da da
unterbricht er mich und erzählt mir er
sei auch schon auf dem kilimandscharo
gewesen
ich frage mich wo kommt das jetzt her
aber dann fällt mir eins vielleicht so
afrika und dann fragt er mich aber im
nächsten schritt also wie ich denn
afrika so und ich sage ja sie sind doch
schon auf dem kilimandscharo gewesen
sagt ja ich bin ja nur wanderer xiii ich
bin nur wandert mit afrikanern schwarz
habe ich gesagt aber die frau die frau
ist ein wunderschönes share incentive
sie ja manchmal bleibt einem das lachen
im hals stecken ist dann aber jetzt
diese frage woher sie kommen die frage
nach der herkunft ist die schon
rassistisch latent rassistisch
ich glaube es ist einfach die frage zu
stellen ob sie angebracht ist das ding
mit der frage ist natürlich dass ich die
frage andauernd gestellt bekomme überall
und einfach mega oft also egal wo ich
bin und wenn man über die frage
nachdenken ist das eine relativ intime
frage auch also wenn sie sich überlegen
wann erzählen sie von ihren eltern in
einem gespräch wenn sie jemanden
kennenlernen der straße schon oder genau
und ist es passiert wirklich manchmal
dass leute an der tramhaltestelle auf
mich zukommen und sagen wo kommen sie
denn eigentlich her und das suggeriert
natürlich auch dass ich nicht von hier
bin also dass das zeigt mir ganz klar du
bist anders und gleichzeitig bin ich in
deutschland aufgewachsen geboren
ich spreche deutsch das ist meine
hauptsprache ich gehöre zu deutschland
und inzwischen auch zur schweiz ich
spreche inzwischen schweizer deutlich
gegen die uni und so weiter dieses
dieses ständige suggerieren dass das man
nicht daher kommt das ist glaube ich
dass das das problem die frage ob das
rassistisch ist ist natürlich heikel war
leute rassistisch sein wollen
[Musik]
ich glaube aber dass wir alle in einem
rassistischen system aufgewachsen sind
und daher gar nicht anders können als
rassistisch zu sein
das heißt dass wir dass es vollkommen
normal ist beispielsweise mit ok man
kann da in gefahr
ich glaube die definition von rassismus
ist erstmal wichtig dass man dass man
sich überlegt okay was bedeutet
rassismus für mich bedeutet das und was
mir ganz besonders wichtig sind sind
zwei komponenten einerseits historizität
also dass irgendwas mit einer geschichte
zu tun hat für mich ganz klar die
geschichte in der festgelegt worden ist
was rassen sind weil es ja eigentlich
gar keine rassen gibt und die andere
komponente ist ist macht also dass es
wirklich auch auswirkungen hat das
jemand rassistisch über dich
denkstrukturen die tief gehen ist war
das ein thema bei ihnen das ist schon da
anfängt in dieser studie mit der frage
woher kommen sie das wurde oft gesagt
und dieser alltagsrassismus der sich
eben mehr die das von ihnen gesagt wurde
mehr durch die repetition eigentlich
mühsam wird der erde ist schwierig
insbesondere auch für jugendliche und
junge menschen die hier aufgewachsen
sind sich genau bewegen wie alle anderen
schweizer genauso angezogen von den
gleichen dialekt sprechen und dass ihnen
dann trotzdem immer diese frage gestellt
wird und das heißt wenn jemand als
touristen oder tourist da ist ist die
frage woher kommen sie eine andere und
liegt anders also eben für mich ist
deutlich wo ist die grenze zwischen
interesse und wo sie vielleicht sagen
ich würde sie sagen subtilen rassismus
ja ich denke schon dass das das subtile
rassismus zum ausdruck kommt letzten
endes macht ja auch der ton ein bisschen
die musik also es kann dann sein dass
sich dahin treten auch diese frage liegt
sicher würden vielleicht gar nicht
hierher das muss nicht sein es kann
natürlich auch ein interesse seien aber
letzten endes muss man ja sehen wie die
die betroffenen darf erleben und ich
finde da ist ganz wichtig dass man eben
mal fragt nach fragt wie geht es ihnen
wenn sie immer wieder gefragt werden
eine frau die wir in der studie befragt
hatten
arbeitet in einem spital und sich aktiv
sie werde jetzt demnächst ein t shirt
tragen wo darauf steht ich komme aus dem
kongo und lebe seit 30 jahren den in der
schweiz weil sie einfach taktisch
gefragt wird und ich glaube nicht immer
mit
den intentionen aber ab und zu ich
glaube so der punkte von der intention
ist auch noch wichtig wenn man über
rassismus redet weil ich glaube dass
intention nichts mit rassismus zu tun
hat natürlich wenn wir über rassismus
reden wollen wir immer über die svp
reden oder aber ich hab schon heraus
gehört bei ihnen wir können gar nicht
anders habe ich vorhin raus gehört in
ihrer studie steht wir haben da ein
zitat vorbereitet alle befragten
personen erwähnen erfahrungen oder
beobachtungen rassistischen verhaltens
situationen oder einstellungen in
unterschiedlichen lebensbereichen
ich finde das ist schon schwer wiegen
diese feststellung also das hat mich
persönlich auch erstaunt also wir haben
ja nur schwarze personen befragt und
alle haben irgendwann selbst oder in
ihrem umfeld rassismus getroffen oder
diskriminierung erlebt und die frage ist
dann natürlich wie schwerwiegend war das
wie häufig ist das passiert da kann man
sich darüber unterhalten aber ich glaube
das kontrastiert ein bisschen mit dem
bild das man sich eben von der schweiz
ab und zu macht wir sind doch ein
weltoffenes land und da gibt es doch
rassismus nicht
also was wirklich präzisieren die studie
heißt amtlich schwarzen rassismus also
explizites nicht allgemein rassistische
diskriminierungen sondern an die
schwarzen rassismus in der schweiz eine
bestandesaufnahme oktober 2017 können
sie uns zwei drei beispiele geben wie
das im alltag vorkommt ja zum beispiel
eine frau die einkaufen will in einem
laden und dann werden plötzlich neben
ihr unten bedient die nach ihr gekommen
sind und sie wird gar nicht gefragt was
sie denn eigentlich kaufen möchte
also dann solche dinge existieren eben
nach wie vor das ist jetzt schon ein
relativ stark dass es muss wirklich mal
fragen also habe gelesen dass beispiele
gibt menschen die dann aufstehen im bus
oder tram wenn sich eine schwarze person
hin setzt das haben wir öfters oder
sogar schwarze menschen anschauen und
ihnen zu verstehen
geben sie müssten aufstehen wenn andere
leute in den bus einsteigen weil die wie
eine art priorität hätten dass das sind
alles ebenso manifestationen die es gibt
ich glaube nicht dass das die mehrheit
wie erleben sie das
ja also ich habe auch noch nie irgendwie
gewalttätigen rassismus an mir selbst
erlebt ich glaube so diesen
alltagsrassismus das ist das ist normal
und das aber eben genau weil es eben
weil wir damit aufwachsen dass es normal
ist dass man zum beispiel gerade nach
dem abitur oder nach der matur nach
afrika reist und die welt rettet es ist
normal dass wir indianer figuren spielen
und überhaupt nicht im kopf haben was
das eigentlich für eine geschichte hat
es ist normal dass david signer zum
beispiel der afrika korrespondent von
der sz jedes mal aufs neue
irgendwie exotische geschichten über
afrika erzählt und haben daher hexerei
und unten dass das prägt uns natürlich
alles entsteht ein bild genau sich und
und dass das muss ich gar nicht erst in
gewalt ausüben also dass das viel viel
von rassismus entsteht ja dann auch
irgendwie in unterbewusst also sachen
dass ich mich nicht neben jemandem
setzte der schwarzes oder ein kopftuch
hat oder irgendwie gefährlich aussieht
dass das kann auch was unterbewusstsein
und er wird ja dann auch immer wieder re
aktualisiert also es ging für diese idee
der wird dann mit der zeit aussterben
und ältere menschen sind ein bisschen
raffinierter als jüngere
aber das stimmt eben nicht weil gerade
wie sie jetzt gesagt haben in den medien
wird und nicht nur da die medien sind
natürlich ein abbild der bevölkerung
aber werden solche bilder auch re
aktualisiert auch durch die politik da
werden sie zum teil sehr gezielt auch
instrumentalisiert racial profiling also
polizeikontrollen mit klarem raster
schwarze meist junge männer ist ein
großes thema in der studie
also bei den schwarzen ich habe gesehen
bei den muslimen kommt dass auch vor
natürlich aber etwas wie
weniger aber bei den schwarzen ist das
ganz klar das thema nummer eins
natürlich er bei den männern aus bei den
frauen obwohl es geht sind beide
geschlechter betroffen und da für mich
ja interessant wie viele leute in der
breiten bevölkerung also nicht nur svp
wähler das tatsächlich unterstützten wie
viele leute sagen ja also was soll man
denn machen es gibt eben mehr schwarze
drogendealer also dass das da diese
logik von die auch durchsetztes mit
rassistischen gedanken dass die
vollkommen normal normal ist also und
das spielt wahrscheinlich zum beispiel
das ist aus den gesprächen hält
vorgekommen dass zum beispiel die
asylpolitik da auch eine rolle spielen
kann dass es nicht bewusst aber das ist
eben diese strukturellen rassismus wo
einerseits eben unerwünschte
asylsuchende im zusammenhang mit
drogenhandel und dann eben mit
kriminalität gesetzt werden und das
wieder ja dass das überträgt sich dann
auch auf die anderen personen überhaupt
nichts mit asyl und schon gar nichts mit
drogen zu tun haben das heißt das sind
wir bei einem thema was rassismus
anbelangt es wird ein bild dann für alle
übergestülpt und wenn es negativ ist ja
wie ist es bei ihrem namen regional
werden sie auch gefragt woher sie kommen
ja das werde ich relativ regelmäßig oder
es gibt auch leute die gar nicht
versuchen meinen namen auszusprechen das
finde ich ist ja nicht so kompliziert es
gibt so ellenlange ruandische nahmen die
wirklich schwierig auszusprechen sind
aber regional wie finde ich jetzt nicht
sehr kompliziert aber effektiv gibt es
leute die fragen da habe ich kein
problem ableben die sich zum beispiel
gar nicht bemühen und mich dann mit
meinem mädchennamen ansprechen und wie
antworten sie auf die frage wenn sie so
oft kommt wie gehen sie damit um
ich habe so verschiedene strategien je
nachdem wie viel kapazitäten und lustig
habe also manchmal spiele ich
tatsächlich das spiel durchaus möglichen
1 aus wirklich und irgendwann sage ich
aus der meiner mama dann ist meist nicht
still
[Gelächter]
inzwischen manchmal finde ich auch
irgendwas je nach dem manchmal dass
burkina faso sierra leone irgendwas
exotisches weil ich das gefühl habe dass
leute das ja auch gar nicht wirklich
wissen wollen die fragen die hinterher
kommen sind immer die gleichen es ist
immer so okay da hab ich dann habe
anfassen oder muss man der kopftuch
tragen also ich hab das gefühl
meistens ist die frage dann auch
irgendwie ein komischer einstieg für ein
gespräch das einem aufgedrückt wird also
ich muss dann mit jemandem über sein
wolle und ihr aufenthalt in kenia leben
also das heißt das heißt ich inzwischen
beantwortet die frage auch gar nicht
mehr ernsthaft außer es kommt wirklich
in einem gespräch das ist ja auch
wirklich was anderes wenn wenn man in
einer situation ist in dem die frage
tatsächlich natürlich gewachsen kommt
das was ich vorhin gefragt hat wo die
grenze ist und menschen interesse und
eben vorgefertigten sozusagen hut der
übergestülpt wird
ich möchte auch ein anderes thema
ansprechen und zwar muslimfeindlichkeit
bundesrat alle besser schreibt im
vorwort zum rassismus bericht des bundes
aus dem jahr 2016
rassismus ist vielfältig
muslimfeindlichkeit rassismus gegenüber
schwarzen gegenüber menschen
mitfahrender lebensweise antisemitismus
und weitere formen haben ihre je eigene
geschichte und mechanismen
wir haben jetzt auch schon differenziert
aber hier in diesem bericht geht es
jetzt wirklich um rassistische
diskriminierung und rassismus wird als
oberbegriff gebracht was ist jetzt
rassismus wie definieren sie das also es
gibt keine allgemein akzeptierte
definition des rassismus dass das ist
wahrscheinlich auch so weil er eben im
verlauf der zeit auch hier sehr
kontroversen oberbegriff wie es hier
gebraucht wird genauso häufig
unterscheidet man zwischen rassistischer
diskriminierung und dem rassismus als
ideologie aber wir haben vorhin gesehen
man muss nicht unbedingt eine ideologie
einer rassistischen
die haben um dann auch rassistisch zu
handeln also das thema was sie
ansprechen möchte ist
muslimfeindlichkeit wird hier auch geht
das auch unter wasser es muss also ich
würde es sagen schon obwohl die frage ob
muslimfeindlichkeit jetzt insgesamt
rassistisch ist oder ob es auch einen
teil gibt die zum beispiel eine gewisse
angst vor den muslimen bezeichnet die
noch nicht direkt mit rassistisch
rassistisch bezeichnet werden konnte
das ist auch umstritten und ich glaube
da kann man die grenzen auch nicht so
genau
4 das heißt aber sie sind muslimin wenn
sie als schwarze und muslimen sind sie
mehrfach von diskriminierung betroffen
ich glaube was man natürlich da noch
dazu sagen muss dass ich kein kopftuch
trage ich bin nicht offensichtlich
muslime
ich glaube dass das leute die die
wirklich offensichtlich muslimisch sind
oder sichtbar ganz andere reaktionen
bekommen und ich weiß von von von
freundinnen dass das die wirklich
tagtäglich auch gewaltvolle übergriffe
haben in form von angespuckt werden
angerempelt werden und bei mir äußert
sich dass er so ab dem moment in dem das
gegenüber erfährt dass ich muslim ich
bin merke ich okay jetzt wird plötzlich
abgecheckt ob ich auch ausrechnen
feministisch sein kann ob ich
menschenrechte unterschreiben würde
und so wird dann geprüft welche art von
islam oder genau aber ich wollte da noch
was dazu sagen ich glaube was was was
bei der frage ob islamfeindlichkeit oder
islamophobie jetzt rassismus ist was bei
der frage wichtig ist ist dass man klar
stellt dass rassismus auch schon immer
was mit mit mit religion zu tun hat
rassismus wurde durch religion ja auch
die wege geleitet und legitimiert und
deswegen kommt ja oft so das argument
islamophobie ist kein rassismus weil
religion ist keine rasse so ein bisschen
komisch einfach weil es rasten ja
sowieso nicht die verbindung führen sie
auf die geschichte zurück und es muss
genau
in dem sohne minderwertigkeit durch
einen nicht glauben an die gleichen
werte oder gleichen götter gottheiten
zurückgeführt wird auf eine allgemeine
menschliche minderheit oder dass du das
dass man wirklich gesagt hat okay dass
das es biblisch belegt dass das keine
menschen sind und deswegen dürfen wir
sie auch abschlachten zu
muslimfeindlichkeit weil ich gerne über
die situation in der schweiz sprechen
möchte aktuell gibt es eine pilotstudie
vom gfs bern pilotstudie
diskriminierungserfahrungen von muslimen
in der schweiz da steht verbreitet sind
insbesondere die ist aktuell januar 2018
verbreitet sind insbesondere direkte und
indirekte erfahrungen von
hasskriminalität und diskriminierungen
und zwar in den allermeisten fällen
eindeutig auf grund der erkennbarkeit
der zugehörigkeit zur muslimischen
gemeinde beispielsweise wegen eines
kopftuchs oder wegen des namens also die
sichtbarkeit ist eben auch ganz wichtig
und kürzlich wurde in deutschland auch
eine studie veröffentlicht wo sie
verglichen haben verschiedene
herkunftsgruppen die sichtbar waren oder
eben nicht also bei ihnen kann man ja
nicht sehen ob sie muslime sind zb aber
je nach dem eben wenn sie ein kopftuch
tragen würden würde man das sehen
und sobald die leute sichtbar sind
werden sie wesentlich mehr diskriminiert
als wenn das eben nicht sichtbar ist
wenn gestern erst in einem gespräch zum
ausdruck kommt und in dem sinn ist also
ich glaube heute ist wahrscheinlich die
muslimfeindlichkeit obwohl es macht
keinen sinn die verschiedenen rassismen
gegeneinander auszuspielen
aber die muslimfeindlichkeit ist relativ
aktuell und öffnet wird fasst vielleicht
noch noch direkter angesprochen als zum
beispiel der rassismus gegen schwarze da
gibt es eine größere zurückhaltung weil
man wahrscheinlich die geschichte kennt
und weiß ich verdient das ist und die
die muslimfeindlichkeit das finde ich
auch erstaunen und das belegen
inzwischen in der schweiz gibt es nicht
sehr viele studien aber es gibt
inzwischen einige und sie belegen alle
dass man sich da ein bisschen gehen
lässt und ich hier gibt es den
erkenntnisse wo die ursachen dafür
liegen also die medien die die
betroffenen muslime in der studie sagen
ja auch und dass sie das gefühl haben
dass das in den medien auch verstärkt
wird und es hat sich etwas damit zu tun
mit dem weltweiten terrorismus und mit
der art wie das eben hier auch
präsentiert und dann rezitiert wie oder
muslimen muslime unter generalverdacht
geraten
also ich glaube dass es da auch
interessantes wenn man also dass die
debatte dann interessantes als
paradebeispiel dafür wie rassismus
eigentlich alle bevölkerungsschichten
auch wirklich durch durchtränkt
wenn man zum beispiel daran denkt wie
wii vollkommen natürliches ist wie über
das kopftuch gesprochen wird
das ist vollkommen akzeptiert es in
unserer gesellschaft dass wir ohne
muslimas zu fragen darüber sprechen ob
es jetzt okay ist oder nicht dass sie
ein kopftuch tragen wenn wir plötzlich
anfangen über werte zu diskutieren und
uns darauf einlassen und darauf
einzuschränken dass die schweiz
bestimmte werte hat und die europäisch
und christlich sind und europa bestimmte
wert hat die dir klar europäische und
christlich sind und dabei die ganze
geschichte in der ja auch
zusammentreffen mit mit dem islam und so
weiter stattgefunden haben einfach
beiseite schiebt und so ein bisschen
unter den teppich schiebt um so eine so
eine lineare geschichtsschreibung von
wir gegen die zu zu machen was dieses
bild nochmals verstärkt es gibt ja
rassistische diskriminierung auch
gegenüber juden juden von einem vorfall
letzten tagen gelesen eine
holocaust-überlebende die umgebracht
wurde ja auch das ist noch aktuell und
ich glaube das unterstreicht auch einmal
mehr dass eben der rassismus sehr
verschiedene gesichter haben kann
und es stimmt dass bei gewissen
ausschließen
beispiel ist wirklich diese idee dass zb
schwarze etwas dünner sind als weiße
dass es so etwas was manchmal welt
kreiert wird bei den juden kommen eben
immer noch so vorurteile wie dass sie
geld süchtig sind dass er seine
weltweite verschwörung gibt und all
diese die diese anachronistische
vorurteile die eigentlich alle widerlegt
sind werten hat einfach immer bietet
trotzdem besprochen und lief sitzen so
gegen ende unseres gesprächs wo setzen
sie an sie geben auch workshops gegen
rassismus was machen sie da konkret
hauptsächlich versuchen wir ich mache
das mit einem kollegen die hauptsächlich
versuchen wir einen raum zu schaffen in
dem offen darüber geredet werden kann
weil man das auch schon in schulklassen
sieht man redet nicht mehr darüber
man hat irgendwie von zu hause von den
medien von überall her irgendwelche
annahmen und und und die sind dann
einfach fest und da sitzen dann
vielleicht zwei kinder in einer klasse
dass wir bei unserem ersten workshops so
der der eine war schwarz und bei der
frage wie oft er kontrolliert wird von
der polizei sagte er
sehr oft den wöchentlich ein 16 jähriger
junge und ob er angst habe vor der
polizei ja und gegenübersitzt von ihm
ein weißer schüler der sagt wenn er
kontrolliert wird was jetzt zwei mal
vorgekommen ist dann fragt er
ich will erst mal ihren ausweis sehen
und so diese diese unterschiede
also ja fragt ein polizist genau da hakt
es im osten nach nachdem was empfehlen
sie aber stoppt moment ihre das will ich
noch fertig sagen dass diese
unterschiede das zusehen mega wichtig
sind um erkennen welche privilegien man
hat oder eine wunsch sei es bildung
diese also ich denke das ist etwas ganz
wichtiges dass wir darüber sprechen und
dass insbesondere die betroffenen
darüber sprechen und eben dass man diese
hemmungen abbaut und eben auch zuhört
weil häufig gibt es so ein bisschen die
reaktion das dann herunterspielen zu
wollen das ist ja nicht so schlimm
und überhaupt und ich habe gemerkt dass
eben auf also das ist uns natürlich bei
der studie von den schwarzen ist das
gespiegelt wurden von der
mehrheitsbevölkerung dass die einfach
zum teil wirklich ein wenig weiß und
sich gar nicht vorstellen kann was das
eben heißt wenn man auf dem schulweg
kontrolliert wird von der polizei aber
ich glaube da ist es ist nicht die sache
von von den betroffenen darüber mehr zu
reden oder sich da mehr politik zu
machen ich glaube das ist genau der
punkt dass das leute die nicht von
rassismus betroffen sind erkennen müssen
und lernen müssen bevor sie sich an den
tisch setzen und über rassismus also
dass man dass man sich weiter schult
darüber welche privilegien man hat dass
man dass man sein auge schult dafür was
wie ich jetzt anders behandelt werden
als die person die da gerade am putzen
es wäre es eigentlich am putzen wer ist
in welcher gesellschaftlichen rolle
was passiert wenn ich mit vollmond esse
wird das auf meinem eine rasse
zurückgeführt so sachen dass ich dass
ich wirklich ein gespür dafür entwickeln
welche stellung in der gesellschaft
haben und nicht wieder abwälze auf auf
die die sich mal wieder integrieren
sollen oder die die einfach den mund
aufmachen müssen noch ganz gut
keinesfalls aber ich finde es ganz
wichtig dass man eben zu hören und
vielleicht auch mal wirklich still ist
und mal zuhört wie geht zb rassismus
erlebt und ich denke die
mehrheitsgesellschaft weist das einfach
nicht hier
ganz herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
ihnen beiden
danke danke auch
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit dem
philosophischen stammtisch und einer
debatte über macht und wirkung der
medien
[Musik]
hallo